[Música]
una de las cosas que más me gustaba
cuando estaba en el colegio era sentarme
en la primera fila del bus con dio para
el boca de sam para recuerdo que me
encantaba hablar con el chófer más que
todo con don waking era demasiado
divertido y resulta que un día en esa
espera de ir al colegio recuerdo que una
mujer joven cargando un bebé en brazos
empezó a hablar nos enseñas yo no estaba
entendiendo nada quedé completamente en
shock el chofer del bus en ese momento
tampoco entendía lo que estaba
sucediendo y entramos en pánico resulta
que la gente seguía subiendo el bus y
seguía interrumpiendo a esta persona que
nos estaba hablando en señas
definitivamente no sabíamos qué hacer yo
y mi desesperación me puse de pie encima
del asiento y trataba de hablarle pero
no había forma de que esta persona me
entendiera de forma apropiada
recuerdo que ser un bus viejo y la forma
que había para cerrar la puerta era
inclinándose a una palanca que el chófer
tenía al frente
recuerdo que el chófer se inclinó y le
cerró la puerta en la cara a esta mujer
yo todavía de pie en el asiento estaba
conmocionada por lo que acababa de ver
podía ver el reflejo de ella a través de
la puerta cargando a su bebé donde
esperó unos segundos para luego
retirarse yo solo me senté en mi asiento
con el corazón destrozado y pensando qué
pasó porque más de 55 personas en ese
bus no pudieron ayudar a esta persona
sorda ahí fue cuando me prometí a mí
misma que esto nunca más me iba a pasar
mientras yo estuviera viva
me di cuenta que las 10 16 años en mi
casa nunca se había hablado sobre
discapacidad mis papás nunca me habían
comentado al respecto pero cada vez que
hablamos de discapacidad tenemos
demasiadas precondiciones demasiados
conceptos pre creados por muchísimas
cosas que escuchamos por ejemplo si yo
les digo discapacidad en este momento lo
primero que se viene a su cabeza es una
persona usuaria de silla de ruedas por
qué porque es lo que vemos en las
noticias es lo que vemos en la
televisión en lo que vemos en las
películas sin embargo existe una gran
variedad de discapacidades que
habitualmente no entendemos y pensamos
que son mitos por ejemplo les puedo
asegurar que la mayor parte de las
personas que están viendo esta
transmisión utilizan lentes si los
lentes forman parte de una condición de
discapacidad condición de discapacidad
de baja visión sorprendido sí pero es
muy común hablar sobre lentes más que
discapacidad es por eso que necesitamos
aclarar estos conceptos ahora qué es
discapacidad tratemos de definir este
término cuando hablamos de la
discapacidad este término ha
evolucionado con el tiempo y por ejemplo
históricamente cuando cuando empezamos a
leer sobre discapacidad nos damos cuenta
que antes se culpaba a las personas con
discapacidad por haber nacido con esa
discapacidad y pues incurrían a matarlos
o con tratamientos como si bañándose con
agua fría se les fuera quitar esa
discapacidad sin embargo este este
concepto evolucionó en varias formas si
definitivamente hay personas que tienen
discapacidad física o discapacidad
cognitiva pero definitivamente esto se
afecta mucho más por el entorno en el
que habitamos
adquiriendo muchas limitaciones muchas
formas de poca comunicación con las
diferentes personas a nivel mundial se
estima que 1.6 mil millones de personas
tienen discapacidad lo que representa un
20 por ciento de la población mundial
ahora ese porcentaje puede variar porque
estamos sumando vejez de la población
enfermedades crónicas que siguen
permaneciendo en la población y ahora
una de las más modernas gracias a la
tecnología la sordera prematura y esto
que se debe por la falta de control en
el manejo de audio de los dispositivos
inteligentes ahora
hablamos más de este tema en el 2007 las
naciones unidas crean la convención de
los derechos para las personas con
discapacidad donde costa rica decide ser
uno de los primeros 50 países en firmar
y decir presente así que el 28 de
setiembre en ti 1 de septiembre del 2008
el 2008 se firma ya lo que es el el
acuerdo en costa rica para que se dé
esta esta aprobación ahora cuál es la
realidad actual de las personas con
discapacidad en nuestra costa rica
después del 2008 más de 10 veces es la
proporción en la que las personas con
discapacidad sufren
son afectados por el índice de pobreza
por otro lado las condiciones de
vivienda son terribles menos del 50% de
la población con discapacidad no tiene
una vivienda digna las mujeres el 78 por
ciento de las mujeres con discapacidad
no tienen trabajo y hay otro porcentaje
ahí que son madres solteras que tienen a
cargo personas con discapacidad y que ni
hablar del servicio público de salud
88 por ciento de las mujeres no asisten
a los centros médicos porque las
instituciones o la infraestructura
física no está creada para personas con
discapacidad y mucho menos los empleados
públicos tienen conocimiento sobre
muchas de las necesidades que estas
personas necesitan ahora esto es la que
más me impacta y la que más me duele la
parte educativa más del 93 por ciento de
las personas con discapacidad no asisten
a las aulas se imaginan ahora esto con
la pandemia pues ha puesto que este
número ha incrementado muchas personas
no logran concluir las clases o educarse
para obtener un mejor trabajo porque
nuestros sistemas no están hechos para
las personas con discapacidad ahora sí
nos podemos a pensar en términos de
números y en términos de exclusión si yo
les dijera que la cantidad total de las
personas con discapacidad según el
consejo nacional de personas con
discapacidad en el censo 2011 estaríamos
excluyendo completamente a la provincia
de heredia
ahora les voy a hacer una pregunta y
quiero que la piensen bien quiero que
piensen bien esa respuesta se ha puesto
a pensar que tan inclusivo es usted
déjenme les planteó la pregunta de otra
forma está usted excluyendo a las
personas con discapacidad de forma
consciente
mientras usted reflexiona en esa
respuesta déjeme le cuento cuál es mi
tarea actual como ingeniera en sistemas
mi responsabilidad actual es proveer
recomendaciones y buenas prácticas para
que las empresas puedan crear productos
digitales para que puedan ser adecuados
para las personas con discapacidad algo
muy importante que quiero recalcar acá
no vengo a hablar en nombre de las de la
comunidad con discapacidad vengo a
hablar como aliada como amiga de
personas con discapacidad como colega de
personas con discapacidad y como miembro
de una familia que tiene personas con
discapacidad ahora qué es la
accesibilidad digital en términos de
explicarse los de forma sencilla voy a
hablar de los desde dos vertientes la
primera porque es un derecho humano
todas las personas sin importar su
condición su género su raza tienen
derecho a la información y más ahora con
toda la tecnología y la tecnología van
rapidísimo en comparación a cómo se
mueve la accesibilidad digital por
supuesto en términos de creación de
productos nos ofrece una oportunidad
grandísima de crear pautas mayor
inclusión digital y poder reducir esa
brecha tan grande que tenemos desde la
parte técnica nos permite crear
productos que de verdad sean accesibles
y que puedan ser accesibles para
muchísimas personas y por supuesto no es
sólo crear un producto que sea accesible
sino que también sea usable y ahí entran
muchísimas partes del desarrollo de
software ahora uno de los retos más
grandes que he tenido como profesional
en el área de accesibilidad es cuando
tengo que hablar con los creadores de
proyectos digitales que no tienen
discapacidad y que empiezan a crear
productos digitales para toda una
población una de las preguntas más
comunes que me hacen es mira mirar y
decirme cuánto es el porcentaje de más o
menos las personas con discapacidad que
podrían usar nuestro producto esa es mi
cara definitivamente para mí me duele
mucho que veamos a las personas con
discapacidad como un número sí es
importante hablar de porcentajes porque
los porcentajes nos ayudan a medir cómo
estamos como estamos trabajando sin
embargo me dirán con discapacidad como
un porcentaje sólo porque sí porque
vamos a cumplir una meta no es adecuado
y déjenme y les cuento por qué carolyn
casey fundadora y creadora de valve five
hundred es una emprendedora en términos
de discapacidad esta persona hizo un
estudio con los mayores
expositores a nivel tecnológico en el
campo internacional las potencias
mundiales e hizo una simple pregunta
mira ustedes incluyen la discapacidad
dentro de sus procesos de planificación
de productos y pues en este momento
ellos le dijeron pues en el 56 por
ciento respondió que más o menos hablan
sobre la discapacidad y la inclusión
cuando crean productos y sólo el 4 por
ciento de esos empresarios con poder de
decisión y de cambiar el mundo deciden
incluir la discapacidad dentro de sus
conversaciones
ahora fue en el 2019 por primera vez que
en el foro económico mundial se habló
sobre la inclusión
habitualmente hablamos que la
discapacidad y la inclusión le pertenece
a otro tipo de esfuerzos al gobierno a
instituciones sin fines de lucro a otro
tipo de personas dentro de nuestra misma
comunidad pero nunca al negocio esto fue
la primera vez en la que se habló a mí
me duele pensar de que pasaran más de
183 años para poder ver la igualdad y mi
sobrina no la va a ver esto es un dato
que el foro económico mundial ha
recolectado durante el paso de los años
ahora imagínense cómo puede ser
incluyendo todo esto qué pasó con el
commit fijo van a ser mucho más de 183
años
para 2018
decidimos retomar
todo lo que es el aprendizaje del esquí
con una amiga y pedimos permiso para ir
a la cafetería incluye me
decidimos seguir y hablar con las
personas de ahí pedimos permiso y pues
resulta que con esta pinta créanme que a
mí se me riman y me empiezan a hablar y
resulta que se acerca a maría alejandra
a hablar con nosotros
resulta que estamos conversando y ella
nos pregunta que porque nosotros
estábamos aprendiendo las cosas y no
teníamos familiares con sordera en
nuestra familia entonces yo le conté la
historia
inmediatamente maría alejandra me agarró
las manos
y me dijo que ya se acordaba de mí
su vida en el asiento el primer asiento
del bus tratando de ayudarle
pero que nunca nunca le pude me puede
ayudar
resulta que maría alejandra fue la que
me dio lo que es la seña actual con la
que me conocen en la comunidad con
discapacidad que es esta
definitivamente hasta ese momento puede
pedirle perdón a alejandro quince años
después por lo que había sucedido ese
día
es decir de verdad necesitamos alzar la
voz desafiar el status quo
salirnos de la caja y empezar a incluir
a las personas con discapacidad porque
nos estamos perdiendo de muchísimas
cosas poderosas destructivas e
innovadoras que nos pueden proveer
muchísimas gracias
[Música]